the two kings of
monster movies are facing each other in
2021
that is if 2020 doesn't end with an
apocalyptic event
but before anything like that happens
let us update you with the three titans
that are confirmed to appear in the
movie
excluding kong and godzilla this will be
a short video as not much information
is leaked or given to us with most of
the speculations and confirmation is
from the toy images of godzilla vs kong
that were leaked
there are also tidbits of info that were
in the redacted wordings and mid-credit
scenes of king of the monsters
we sure hope that there will be more of
these talents that would be shown in the
movie
next year but till now we will have to
contend with the five that are known
so the first one is nozuki or warbat
the first item is as some have known
since april or earlier this year
this is an original monster vs thailand
got nozuki
and later renamed as warbat this
creature would likely not be the only
one of its kind but might be a
swarm-like species called the nuzuki
following a bigger specimen called the
warbat but then again
that's just our speculation his or her
body seems to be mostly green colored
with a red underbelly but
the earlier toy that was released
earlier looked brownish
tan in color this nuzuki or otherwise
called warbat appears to be like a
winged serpent like creature with yellow
and red coloured wings
if it is closely inspected we would see
that the serpent has strange wings that
jut
out from the spines of the creature
these wings are most probably used for
either gliding or for intimidation
and not for flying and come to think
about that a titan that big would glide
from where exactly
okay so this fact is clear that the most
of us prides itself
in putting a realistic feel into the
designs of the titans
they could also be frills that make the
creature look bigger than it really is
for intimidation
or would be used for moving in the
hollow earth or underwater
only time will tell so this serpent also
has a long slender body that would be
hundreds of meters long
as it was not seen and awaken or even
hearing guidorus or godzilla's alpha
call it will probably be another
alpha-class titan that refuses to join
the other beaters
as for the location of where it resides
or hibernates is up to debate
mid-credits scenes clippings of
coordinates pointing towards
gobekli tepe in southern turkey might be
one probable area
and another one might be that it will be
awakened when humans venture into the
hollow earth
with the heav or the hollow earth
anti-gravity vehicle
beneath skull island so going to the
second one
we have the alpha skull crawler so up
next we have this big skull crawler
one which is rumored to be even bigger
than the one that fought kong
in the 2017 skull island movie like most
other skull crawlers which are
large reptilian creatures with only two
four limbs and no hind limbs as well as
long
prehensile serpentine tails and they
also have
long slender yet muscular sturdy bodies
several aspects of their
appearances are noticeably skeletal
particularly
their torsos and their heads and this
new one
seen as a part of the leaked toy images
seems to be just like the older ones but
with small minor changes
this new skull crawler or as i would
like to call it the alpha skull crawler
has reddish skin on its back and it
starts from the base of the head
and the neck what does it mean we don't
know yet but it could most probably
be a coloration that an alpha of a
species attains
when it reaches a certain size or status
this alpha also has bigger arms with
more musculature
and seems to be half the height of
godzilla but equal in length
it still has its long prehensile tail
which would be a very deadly weapon
against other titans so i'm guessing
that it wouldn't be a main villain but
somewhat of a first level boss fight
that would build up the suspense before
fighting the final boss
maybe and the third titan that was
confirmed is mecca godzilla
as seen in the news clippings of
godzilla king of the monsters monarch
was actively building a mechanized titan
in order to face off
against the other super species threat
that humanity suddenly faced
in the previous movie imagine during the
events of kotm most of humanity
thought that godzilla was the only titan
alive but all of a sudden
their cities and populations face
constant attacks from these gigantic
unstoppable foes it would make sense
that humanity would pull in all their
resources
to build mechanized titans to battle
these new threats much like the jaegers
of pacific rim
so in the leaked toy images we see that
mechagodzilla has a very different
design
although not diverging far from the
original concept this maker godzilla had
robots
arms and legs and that the hands possess
oversized fingers which could use to
grab godzilla or be used to clench to
form a powerful fist for combat
this mecca also had a long reddish spiny
tail with hundreds of reddish segments
that start from the body
and to the tip the head was designed to
look like godzilla himself
in another toy we can see that a
godzilla figure wrapped by
similar reddish segments which might be
an armor or a power up
but that's for another video of
mechagodzilla and mega godzilla
differences
so that's that here we have the three
other titans that will be joining kong
and godzilla in the 2021 movie
these titans again is the snake serpent
with red wings called nozuki or warbat
the giant skull crawler that looks like
it has reddish skin
on its back and the mechanized titan
that we so
wanted badly mecha godzilla anyways
thanks mind keywords and
be sure to hit that bell button for
regular updates on monster videos